you are voting for joe biden i'm
assuming
i'm not saying who i'm voting for and as
he's not saying she's voting for but i'm
not looking for trump
megan mccain didn't exactly reveal who
she's voting for in the 2020
presidential election
but she's definitely not here for trump
i understand the other side a lot
clearer than when i was working at fox
obviously that just happens when you're
around a different environment on watch
what happens live the view co-host
revealed her suggestions for joe biden's
highly anticipated ready mate
announcement
i think if he's smart he'll choose
someone like tammy deckworth because
she's very hard to attack because she's
a veteran
and she has such a long history tammy
duckworth is the current junior u.s
senator from
illinois and was a former lieutenant
colonel in the u.s
army i would do whatever i need to do to
help joe biden get elected
so that we can finally turn the corner
in this country and get back on a path
where we need to be as for who mccain
thinks biden
shouldn't pick i know that there's a
huge debate that people want a black
woman to be chosen
um i know 100 who he shouldn't pick i
don't i don't think susan rice is a good
choice at all
because she's never been elected to
anything yep susan rice a black woman
who served as the u.s ambassador to the
united nations
and as the u.s national security advisor
i care
fundamentally about one thing and that
is that joe biden win
uh that we win the senate and that he
has the opportunity to govern
with the strongest team possible and i'm
prepared to support
him in any possible way that he thinks i
can
mccain and biden have had a super close
bond in the past
but she admits that they haven't spoken
much recently
i haven't talked to him in a little
while but up until he
started running for president it was
pretty frequent but i you know he's very
busy
so i only try and contact them if i
really really need something and i
haven't recently
this isn't the first time mccain has
been vocal about her 2020 vote
here's what she told andy cohen in april
i keep telling everyone i will
promise you you will know who i'm voting
for but it really shouldn't take a
rocket scientist to know there's one man
who
has made pain in my life a living hell
and another man who has like
literally shepherd me through the grief
process this
really shouldn't be rocket science for
people the talk show host is currently
pregnant with her first child
and on wednesday she totally shut down
rumors that she's not returning to the
view
after the baby is born why does everyone
ask me if i'm getting fired or quitting
every 20 seconds
no other host has to deal with this bs
yes i'm coming back it's an election
[Music]
cycle